this episode is sponsored by the amazon
fire tv omni series
[Music]
after taking audiences deep into the
world of blade runners mexican drug
cartels and the spider-verse
french canada's greatest hero since
whoever put gravy on cheese curds is
back with an adaptation of a novel that
seems really dense but at its core is
about getting high while your workaholic
parents are distracted i'm sorry sir
won't happen again go
they said frank herbert's epic tale was
unfilmable and for a time it looked like
they were right or at least mostly right
i did not say this
i am not here
but denive in the news epic new vision
proves that the secret to the perfect
adaptation was staring us in the face
all along
just do half and worry about the rest
later
hey we're great for george rr martin
he'll wrap up wins a winner right after
this blog post about new york football
okay this one
this one
after this one
okay okay one more
okay two more
and that's just from this season
it's ten thousand years in the future
and the only surviving piece of earth
culture is the bagpipes
this civilization runs on spice magic
sparkle dust that enables space travel
and makes bagpipes sound like way better
man the emperor has awarded house
atreides control over the desert planet
arrakis the universe's only source of
spice but he has a secret plan to betray
them along with baron harkinin what
darth vader's left nut looks like under
the armor but luckily the atreides have
some of the galaxy's most brilliant
tacticians skilled warriors and they're
well aware they're entering a trap so
there's plenty of time for them to
still get their asses pounded into the
sand like anakin burnt watto's dinner i
don't like sand
now the only hope for the future of the
house of hotties is sad boy paul who
picked the worst possible planet to be
an emo kid he's a lonely sullen teen
with psychic powers who would be a
perfect fit in the x-men universe
unfortunately on a ruckus professor x
just teaches you how to recycle your
piss inside the mask you'll find a tube
to allow you to drink the recycled water
and how do electric slide across the
desert like a bar mitzvah dj with heat
exhaustion follow me do the same moves
they did not need to adapt this part
with their house nearly destroyed paul
and his mommy will set off on a
treacherous journey in search of the
freman blue blue-eyed stand-ins for
oppressed civilizations who believe
everything and i do mean everything is
best settled via knife fight
[Music]
in fact most of the conversations in
this film take place at knifepoint your
permission siren must check the
integrity of you
oh
i have you all
you to join me in death remove your hand
from the box
and you die
they're a cross between the navi and the
ewoks who sound like they make a mean
is young
you can't learn our ways and the most
enchanting member of their tribe is
zendaya's chaney
watch her briefly look over her shoulder
for seven total minutes of screen time
but she sticks around long enough to add
another notch to her cute little white
boy belt pucker up in wolfard you're
next
they're joined by a massive ensemble of
beloved character actors speaking three
monotone lines apiece like it's an
audition tape for yale drama including
polka dot man as a human computer who
dies right away
thanos has a well-meaning aristocrat who
disappears right away aquaman who dies
but only after a while and poe dameron
as a space aristocrat who dies right
away because if he were on the screen
any longer the audience would die from
excessive horniness
but hey at least batista survives
doesn't do too much besides stand there
with his mouth open but he's alive gotta
give him that
so whether you catch it on the big
screen or hbo max or skip it entirely to
focus on twitter arguments about where
movies are supposed to be watched
prepare for a film with more stunning
visuals of giant hovering spaceships
then jeff bezos powerpoint drafts folder
that's definitely among the best films
of 2021 as long as you've already read
the book and can fill in all the missing
character development don't care that it
randomly ends halfway through the actual
story or oblivious to the fact that the
middle east actually has a number of
professional actors and have two and a
half hours to kill watching a contract
dispute between the exxon mobils of
tomorrow but hey if you don't watch it
now you'll be totally lost when they put
harry styles in the metal underwear for
part two
starring
wonka vision
trans moms the spice must po
the mandala
shaved batista
zendaya
dunkin donuts
moving to the desert gonna find me a lot
of speeches dry dock and just the tip
yeah they probably won't hang full warm
until dune five when paul's kid makes
himself into one and befriends the
reanimated corpse of jason mamoa the
books get real weird strap in folks
very spies
i'm sorry but what the heck is this a
giant ant with human hands can't just
lay this on us and move on to me i don't
care how much ground you have to cover i
demand context
this episode is sponsored by the amazon
fire tv omni series get amazon's first
hands-free tv at amazon.com today
when you see the baron remember the
tooth
save the hacker hack the world
how dare you look at me in that tone of
voice